good morning millennials
welcome back to the toast happy
Wednesday it's hump day which is so
appropriate because I want to hunt my
co-host because you look so stunning do
I actually because I just I need to get
this off my chest first of all I'm fresh
off a red eye yes but I wouldn't look it
you wouldn't however however I was just
in San Diego and I asked a hairstylist
to do a micro trim okay that's psychotic
to get a haircut like not with your
go-to person in another state I was
desperate Claudia come on Claudia my
bangs were completely grown out my hair
was like scraggly like it needed to
happen I could not deal with it that's
psychotic but sure and I knew I wouldn't
have time to get in this week because I
leave on Friday
she chopped my hair off
like it's I when I go in for a haircut I
go in like it's a surgery yeah it is it
is and I'm so serious about micro trim
one eighth of an inch why do you think
my hair is up right now okay I just want
to say your hair looks great even though
it's up I can't say
um and I want to feel bad for you but
going to a new salon in a new state with
a person you've never used is so like
such a mentally ill thing to do I can't
even feel bad for you
I did research especially when like like
me you seem very particular about it
some people are like yeah just cut my
hair not me but some people are like
that so you're particular and you still
went and did that what if you knew you
had to look very great for something
over the weekend and you wouldn't be
able to see someone in New York the
devil you know I know what my hair looks
like without a haircut and the devil you
don't know is this new international
hair cutter that is so true the devil
you know I should have just let it be
scraggly yeah better scraggly than
something you really don't like even
though you look beautiful you can't look
bad my hair is up right now so wear your
hair up this weekend oh my God all
weekend where are you going that's going
to be somewhere so fabulous that you
need to look so standing for Las Vegas
what for
are you gonna say [__] no you do not
need to look that fabulous yes by the
way you need to look fabulous in Vegas
um there is an opening they're opening a
cathedral there oh towel group oh cool
and I was invited by one of my friends
fun and so I was like you know what
single me I'm [__] going well let's
talk about that
I feel like I just like completely took
over your podcast like diary of the
mouth that's the point
um you're single I'm single but you were
seeing someone I was seeing someone I
wasn't like very very public about it
for obvious [__] reasons
but we dated for I don't know roughly a
year it thought oh wow and then I was
like Sophia you're 30. and if you don't
see this being your husband time to
knock it yeah yep right yeah you're are
you and I the same age uh please don't
age me I'm 28. but I'm literally a month
away from turning 29 so like yeah we're
the same age okay great are you a cancer
I am what are you a cancer I don't see
you as a cancer I don't see horoscopes I
don't believe in them I don't understand
them I think it's fraudulent so that
makes sense that you wouldn't see me as
a cancer you're Leo oh okay I'm not I'm
literary cancer but Okay Sophia keep
telling me what I am I will
um do you so you don't want to be single
I feel like you for a while were like
like being single okay so I
I'm a total serial monogamous oh wow to
a very unhealthy degree yeah
AKA my relationships will overlap oh
which is a form
that as a serial monogamous but continue
continue that's actually the most like
eloquent gracious way to say it yeah
like I'm so obsessed with relationships
sometimes I'll be in two at once yeah
sometimes they overlap uh so that's been
me for the last I don't know 10 years of
my life
and so this is the first time I have
been single since I swear to God High
School oh wow which is scary yeah but I
feel like you know your experience being
single and maybe I'm just romanticizing
it because I think the world of you
you're like this fabulous stunning
gorgeous like it must be so fun for you
to be single does everybody want a piece
of Sophia with an F no no no I mean I
mean some people do but I'm depressed
really this this breakup is very recent
oh like I'm not running around
gallivanting I mean I am but I'm CR like
I'm dying inside but you're crying when
you get home yeah exactly okay that's so
relatable Sophia but I think it will go
away the single dumb or the depression
both hopefully here's hoping
well you look great I'm so excited that
you're back on the toast it's been so
long and everybody loved Sophia yanglin
last time I am gonna kill you for
calling me that Sophia yanklin is that
you said l-o-l I love Sophia England
Sophia yanklin is that because
um my therapist is assistant did Texas
yeah you told that story last time on
the toast that you said oh yeah it's
Sophia with an f and so she wrote hey
fofia Insanity
f-o-p-h-i-a Insanity I do not see that
therapist anymore by the way that's good
are you in therapy of course what do you
talk about is that an okay question to
ask because I don't go to therapy so I
don't know like you don't no Claudia
it's not that I'm against it at all I
just feel like I'm not like like your
life is like I don't know it's going
pretty good no my life is not going like
um it's like my life is like everyone's
life it's good and bad at times I'm
actually having a great week right now
you know but next week will probably be
terrible okay
um but I feel like I actually
um I handle things very decently
um what does that mean what does that
look like it looks like I don't talk
about anything and then last night I had
a full-blown mental breakdown watching
an episode of Young Sheldon I was so
triggered by this episode can I tell you
what happened do you watch young
children no I don't even know what that
is okay let me tell you you know the Big
Bang Theory yes the dumbest show I think
it's stupid I think it's stupid I think
everyone on a tux like I hate it I love
my umbiolic
thank you but they made a spin-off show
about the character Sheldon they did a
spin-off show of like what his life was
like being like a child genius growing
up in like the 80s in like South Texas
or whatever and it's like such a dumb
concept and I don't even like Big Bang
Theory but I really watched an episode
like on a plane and it was such a
heartwarming such a cute sitcom that I
started it from the beginning me and Ben
are obsessed so Bia it's got heart it's
got comedy it's got science it's the
best [__] show and it's a spin-off of
The Big Bang Theory which we just said
which was his spy exactly but it's like
a prequel I think you just watched so
much television but at this point you're
like I'll try anything yes you'll take
we can go okay but let me tell you
that's not what's happening here because
this show is so good and Sheldon is like
his dad says football coach and I lost
my dad very young and his dad is his
football coach they really don't have a
lot in common because Sheldon is like
this big nerd and he just cares about
like science and stuff and his dad is
like football football very Texas
barbecue beer you know Etc and they take
a trip like a a trip his dad drives him
to go to Florida when the one of the
Rockets from NASA is going to take off
I'm trying not interested right now but
all I'm trying to say was like this
episode with like this this father
trying to help his son and it ended up
being like one of the best weekends of
the son's life and he never got to tell
his dad that because he ended up passing
away I'm just like oh okay something
[__] hit me from left field and I
cried for 25 minutes literal tears oh no
no
oh well I'm sobbing SOB Ben like had to
hold me I was uncontrollably stopping
some things like with grief like some
things just hit you like that you don't
expect and I don't cry every day I don't
even cry every week or really every
month but every now and then something
random and there was this episode of
Young Sheldon okay hit me [__]
sideways that were you on an airplane no
I was in my bed last night okay I was
gonna say maybe the altitude I'm very
attuned to my emotional Awareness on
planes but that wasn't it so what about
just you and your life yeah and people
doing something hurtful to you in real
life I feel like that doesn't even
affect you oh that's interesting is that
what people go to therapy for
I don't think they go for Sheldon
whatever whatever
no I think they go for Sheldon I really
do think oh okay how do I handle like
any sort of adversity or challenges like
in my relationships is what you're
saying yeah
um well I have a very small circle very
I feel like you do not let people in no
and part of that is like a general
disinterest but part of that is like
also if you cross me even once remotely
by accident like I don't really feel
like where the com the relationship is
worth pursuing okay
um so I'm at a place in my life where
everyone who's in my life like we get
along is that weird like it's mostly
like family and like five friends
actually that's how I am yeah I really
have a friend group of about five people
and then my family yeah yeah and that's
how I keep it and those like if there's
any sort of confrontation with anybody
in that group like I know it's worth
right working through right but
sometimes you ever have a friendship or
like a relationship where it's like they
hurt you but like you don't even care
that much about the Friendship so it's
like what we're gonna get down to the
bottom of this and have awkward
conversations when I don't even care no
that's never happened to me no that's
how I feel like somebody does something
to me and Ben's like well you should say
some I'm like but I don't really care
but okay but I want to know what that
means someone Crossing you oh I have a
very low bar for friendship honestly
like I just like if you betray my trust
oh okay that's it a hundred percent like
I don't care you consider like you like
a boy that I like or whatever I don't
know what people fight about I don't
care you literally if you tell someone
something I told you in confidence I'm
done that's the only thing I care about
I am totally on board and then we just
like we have to get along and you have
to be able to take a joke right but I
mean like there's no like turbulence
like work wise in your relationship of
course no there's very there's
turbulence work-wise in my relationship
yeah yeah but I either ignore it okay or
I work through it ignore it or work
through it with work stuff like I ignore
it like if something's Weighing on me
work-wise like I seriously just ignore
it until it goes away and with Ben we
have um pretty decent communication like
sometimes you know it blows up but every
now like we we have decent communication
okay great so I don't know I'm not
against their at all I've done it before
mostly for my grief
um but then they just want to talk about
it it's like I'm good so that yeah
that's that is what therapy is I'm just
I'm looking at you with like
just complete jealousy because I have
been going to therapy since diapers I
think it's great but I don't get how
you've never gone to like one session no
I have I've gone to probably three total
yeah with like three different
therapists because I don't like them
each time I left okay see this is what
the issue is and why didn't you like
them well first I like that you're
flipping the interview on me okay yeah
first I didn't like it because
um
the first time the person was like
Taking Liberties in the sense that like
I was sharing information about my life
and they were um Googling you no well
that's like a big fear of mine but like
I was talking about how my dad passed
away he died of a heart attack and later
on in the session she was like well do
you think that's because you know your
dad died of obesity I'm like excuse me I
didn't [__] say that uh is that crazy
that's done she's done maybe she got her
wires crossed but I think maybe she was
just like extrapolating like oh here's a
fat [__] maybe like her dad was fat
like I did not like that I did not like
that you think that's what it was I
don't know I don't know but it's me or
maybe she got confused maybe her client
before had a dad who died of obesity
that's a horrible horrible therapist so
I moved on yeah then the next one was
this really lovely older gentleman and I
really felt like he was a nice guy but
he could not understand for the life of
him what I do for a living bye and at
the time so much of my anxiety was
coming from like work stuff so what's
the point right so it's just been like a
series of mismatches now I feel like an
[__] because now I understand the
Sheldon thing
right now I feel like a huge option I
need to look at the park out of this
room now I understand it you had every
right to be triggered yes I was
triggered oh my god of course I was
triggered and the dad is like this cute
like old and he dresses kind of like how
my dad used to dress like he's always
going boating and I was just triggered
by this show and honestly I don't think
I can watch it anymore but it's because
of that but it's so good maybe it could
be like healing to to watch the next
episode and just see how you feel maybe
Sheldon Will Heal Me Maybe you'll be my
therapist yes okay we got off track and
like you're turning the tables on me and
I don't like no well and I don't have a
dad he's never been in my life so maybe
so maybe that's why that's why you can't
relate
sting yeah we're opening up and we're
finding new layers of each other here
that's what we do do we get this deep we
do sometimes we get deep like I'm not
I'm not weird about being vulnerable
especially I feel like when you have a
podcast you can't be you can't are you
weird about like opening up about
certain things no
mine sometimes I take it too far too I
gotta stop doing that I'm not gonna stop
doing that no it's what makes us
authentic podcasters thank you how's
everything going at Sophia with an F
great yeah amazing I you know it took me
like a second to find my footing after
everything but now I feel like I'm in a
place where we can really just hone in
and just go and you get great guests I
do anyone big coming up that you want to
share
um I actually do have someone big coming
up but I don't want to share because I
don't want to spoil it however I would
like to say
part of the reason I'm just super proud
of how far I've come and by I mean we my
team I have had no help from an agency a
manager you know a publicist it was very
much like bootstrap every single guest
we've had every account yes yeah every
single one that's great every brand deal
is negotiated by me and my small team of
three other people right right no it
feels better when you do it that way
especially when you had to rebuild I've
had to rebuild many times and to to
accomplish things when you've really
started at zero feels it feels better it
feels better like it feels so good it
does and you can feel so proud of
yourself especially as a girl like it's
just so hard I mean I never feel like
great about anything like taken
seriously not even taken seriously I
just think I'm very extremely
self-critical yeah of course and I think
that's something I definitely need to
work on in therapy it's it's this
feeling of I could always be doing more
I know that's like a toxic trait of I
think like the business we're in and
people just like comparing themselves to
others and seeing what other people are
doing and it just creates this like for
me it's like a jealousy mentality like I
see other people I'm like I'm jealous
and I want to do that and then you like
run yourself into a hole it is it has a
lot to do with the comparison [__] it's
just competitive competition is good
yeah but to a point it becomes toxic
yeah you are very good though at getting
content out I mean The Daily Show
doesn't hurt
you do the show Daily yeah we're a daily
show that is absolutely nutty I know and
you are my my idol and that's incredible
every single Monday through Friday not
Saturday I would never work on the
weekend
Sunday no oh my God you are a Workhorse
I know have you always been like that no
no no it was like always my my goal to
not really work
right I've never like dreamed of working
in a sense like I think some people like
dream of being a doctor like I dreamed
of a lot of things and being a housewife
well yeah but not not even that like
none of my dreams ever really had
anything to do with work like work for
me was always just like going to be
something that sustained my other dreams
you know like going to Fiji or something
exactly but some people have like career
driven goals I was really never one of
those people but I kind of fell into
this business and then the more success
I started to have it was just directly
correlated to how much work I was
putting in
so is that how much your word I know
it's so annoying like you get in what
you put out I had no clue it's so
annoying because I I mean if you think
about it in my past
I A lot of it was like just me being so
talented well no what happened to you
was actually just so crazy and it's one
of those like very um random not random
because it is Talent based but one of
the Liar's situations yeah where it's
just one day everything flips and you're
doing millions of downloads like most
people most people will build and build
and build to get to that place like a
Joe Rogan type but when you were doing
caller daddy and you were the one of the
two biggest podcasts on the planet that
was just like so overnight almost I'm
sure that's how it felt for you a
thousand percent and then to have to
restart a year later and rebuild you've
actually had both experiences yeah you
now are at a place with your podcast
where you have like a really good
community and a big audience and you've
built that solely week after week after
week whereas with color daddy it was
almost instantaneous because I think you
just went viral and you had the Barstool
machine behind you yep and it was like
instantaneous and that's really not how
it is no everyone no and I'm learning
that also it was
just like that taken away oh well that's
I mean that's why you go to therapy
no no I've gone to therapy way before
that but like I definitely doubled the
dose and now we're back to one time a
week no anyone who's ever been through
any sort of like internet drama where
they were technically like the villain
or the one being canceled needs years
and years of therapy and maybe that's
why I should go to therapy okay so yeah
I would agree with that I love how you
say that but you're like I've never gone
really I do a Daily Show like when can I
go to therapy it's true I need to stop
with the therapy and all the [__]
and get content out and work more would
you ever film your therapy sessions for
a podcast
no that's so personal that's crazy
that's psychotic that's like I mean
unless we have like a certain topic but
like I'm not gonna like relive my
childhood trauma no that's so and just
drag people through the [__] dirt but
that's what people do on reality TV I
feel like on Kardashians on housewives
we're always like sitting in on people's
therapy sessions I'm like this feels a
little too real that is so [__] true
isn't it weird do you but there has to
be like there are certain things that
are just completely off topic
interesting so in terms of like public
life well like the Kardashians oh yeah
there's definitely like actual things
that go on there's a list of things that
you do not with Kardashians I feel like
those therapy sessions are definitely
like really fake and manipulated um but
on reality TV like right now on Real
Housewives of New Jersey like her and
her husband Jennifer Aiden are going to
couples therapy and it's like really
[__] personal and I'm like we don't
need to see this I don't imagine having
a camera wouldn't you just like
instinctively and I'm query authentic
yeah there are certain things that I
would just myself up Yeah a hundred
percent not a lot of things but certain
me too everyone has their own things and
when you're in like public life like
it's okay to have certain things that
you don't talk about I'm very okay with
that boundaries you're drinking a spritz
at 10 30 in the morning and that's why
we stand Sophia with enough if this
flavor is incredible I know it's
incredible and how I'm brand that I'm
doing that I know she's such a
supportive Queens birdsociety.com
um you ready to dive in we're gonna do
pop culture today's also Wednesday and
we have a bunch of girls who need our
advice and actually feel like you'd be
good at giving advice I'm very good at
giving advice so you're gonna help me
out with some girls who are going
through some things amazing so here are
the past five stories that you you yeah
you need to know today's episode is
brought to you by Lululemon the new
Lululemon align collection is fabulous
the pants I wear quite literally every
day that happen to be in the wash today
because I've worn them so much are from
the Lululemon align collection the line
collection is fabulous let me tell you
why I've been loving the high-rise Flair
pant but they also have cute little
biker shorts they have really great
options and the flexibility in these
pants is next level it's a four-way
stretch and that means you can Bend
stretch move literally any way you want
without restriction or distraction I've
been doing my physical therapy exercises
in my flare pen and they've been
extremely supportive they're really
comfortable they're made with nulu
fabric and it's the softest comfiest
texture your legs have ever felt period
the fit is also great it shapes
perfectly to your body for a very
flattering look that is Uniquely Yours I
feel like they hug me in all the right
places they suck me in in all the right
places and I'm just like looking
stunning and I look like I could be
going to a business meeting or to the
airport I just look like comfortable but
also funky fresh you know they're also
weightless it's a light weightless
Sensation that feels like you are
wearing nothing and nothing else so
everyone knows Lululemon is the best in
the game and this align collection is
really taking things to the next level
they're super cute but they're also
really comfortable really flexible just
perfect to wear every day whether you're
working traveling being a mom whatever
it is these pants will support you in
whatever Endeavor it is that you are
currently embarking on so get into the
Lululemon align collection it's
available at lululemon.com that is of
course u l u l e m o n.com and it is the
new Lululemon align collection you don't
want to miss it today's episode is also
brought to you by Squarespace all right
Squarespace is the end-all be-all it is
the place to go for websites so if
you've been thinking about starting a
blog or a side hustle something in
e-commerce and you don't know where to
start check out Squarespace because uh
it's the place to be from websites
online stores marketing tools analytics
Squarespace is the all-in-one platform
to build a beautiful presence online and
run your business so I have built many
websites in my day I think you all
forget I started this thing as a as a
Blog I was a blogger back in the day and
I've used a lot of platforms to build
websites because I'm not an engineer and
I don't have a background in like
computer science or coding and
Squarespace makes it so easy like you
will get a website that looks
professional that has all the
professional tools that the real pros
have but you really you know didn't try
that hard Squarespace did the whole
thing for you they have gorgeous
templates they have great tools for
e-commerce great tools for analytics
great tools for um engaging your social
media and bringing that content onto
your website or promoting your social
media for whatever purpose you're using
the website for
um and of course we have a code when you
go to squarespace.com toast you'll get a
free trial and then when you're ready to
launch use the offer code toast to save
10 off your first purchase of a website
or a domain so again that's
squarespace.com
t-o-a-s-t you get a free trial and then
once you're ready to launch you can use
the code toast to save 10 on your first
purchase of a website or a domain they
can help you with everything Soup To
Nuts start to finish on starting a
website and it's really the place to be
so make sure you're heading to
squarespace.com toast for your free
trial and then use code toast when
you're ready to shop
um some Wedding Bells I don't know if
you saw American hero Olympic gymnast
Simone biles got married I did and she
wore a dress that was 120 and her shoes
were thirty five dollars right right so
do you want me to comment on that I will
let me give you the details and then I'd
like to take you so Olympic gymnast
Simone biles announced her wedding to
the Houston Texans player Jonathan Owens
on Saturday and she's shared some couple
some pictures of The Gorgeous couple on
Instagram so she wore a dress with four
tiers it had Ruffles and she shared on
her Instagram story that her beautiful
gown was from an online boutique called
Selfie Leslie and it retails for 120 she
also shared that her shoes were from
Amazon and they cost thirty five dollars
now
this could never be me
um especially if I'm a you know a
world-renowned Olympic gymnast Simone
biles probably has so much money she's a
she's so brand safe she's an American
Legend like Wheaties you know the whole
thing so that could never be me but it
is important to note this was her
Courthouse she does have a big wedding
coming up okay and if you knew what I
wore to my courthouse wedding you would
be like Claudia shut up you can't say
anything
what so the morning of I knew I wanted
to like wear like a really kind of like
funny
um funny yeah I'd like always have to be
funny it's so annoying I wanted to go to
a costume store and buy and I got
married in September so like all those
Halloween spirit pop-ups were open and I
wanted like a um very much giving Katie
Herron energy at um Aaron Samuel's
Halloween party where she directs us oh
yes twice yes yeah so I wanted like a
big kind of funny satirical wedding
dress and so not with blood and [__] no
well that wasn't the goal okay okay but
I went to Spirit Halloween in the
morning of and I thought there would be
like a million wedding dresses I don't
know why I thought that and there
weren't there were just ghost wedding
dresses so I did end up dressing as like
an apocalyptic bride it was like this
kind of um Smoky very like ripped very
Apocalyptic Zombie Wedding and I I wore
it because it was I waited till the last
minute and it was all that I had and the
person that whatever puts the mirroring
name yeah did they say anything
um no because if you spend any time at
City Hall you know like the [__]
freaks of the century go down there and
like do weird [__] and stand outside and
like I was just one of the many freaks
that day okay yeah so they didn't even
bat an eyelash not a single one was bad
was Ben dressed up no Ben came from work
and he's wearing like a polo and khakis
you know who I don't know how I feel
about her but Emily Ratajkowski her
little pet like pants suit that she wore
to the courthouse I thought that was
really cool she's so Chic and cool and
she's like famous in a model and it has
a stylist so it's like not that hard not
all of us I mean she's not going to
Spirit Halloween in the morning after
the courthouse so we're just like
different girls in that sense but yes
that's a berry you know who looked so
[__] fabulous at their courthouse
wedding of course Jackie O
I don't know I don't know yes I don't
know what she wore she wore this like
but she's always dressed she's always
stylish but she wore this like um this
white get up but she on top wore this
like really Chic pale pink Petticoat
like not Petticoat like I don't know
what the right word is but she looked so
I'll find a picture a Blazer no no it
was like a like a floor length but like
a teacup length pink I don't know what
the right word is because I'm not like a
fashion girl like but a really Chic coat
your sister looks like she could be a
Kennedy well you know what I'm saying
she could be as you you but I think it's
just the red hair the way she dresses
it's her porcelain skin the porcelain's
it the person's skin so what do you
think about what do you make of this
queen celebrity Rich Olympian wearing an
outfit that costs 155 dollars so this is
how I feel about it I'm the same as you
could never be me however we all know
the saying it's not what you wear it's
who's wearing it yeah it's like how you
feel and Simone biles I mean her body
just her as a person she can get away
with anything I'm interested to know why
she broadcasted she did a q a somebody
asked where did you get your dress and
choose from and she said Courthouse
shoes were from Amazon not comfortable
at all then I changed into a different
one my dress is from selfie Leslie
everything was ordered this week the
dress the wedding the shoes the bouquet
okay so I wasn't prepared that's a
little bit of a contradiction there to
get your shoes from Amazon and then your
dress ethically sore right right I know
there's like a little bit of a conflict
there too yeah but I I don't hate it not
you trying to cancel Simone biles I'm
not trying to cancel Simone I'm trying
to cancel Jeff Bezos the one I'd wonder
I'm never trying to cancel Jeff Bezos I
know Amazon is like Fast fashion and
that's not gonna stop me from getting 65
deliveries I use I use Amazon all the
time just just bothers me oh and his
girlfriend wife she bothers me too
breaking up a happy marriage
um just I I really can't stress how like
Samoa it's so hard to shop you know when
you are a woman with you know roles and
whatever and she is like quite literally
like a body perfected by science like
she has a perfect body and she has
unlimited unlimited well not unlimited
but a huge budget yes and this this
could just never be me and I want us you
know I want to commend her but this is
what I always say like Taylor Swift her
song paper rings I like shiny things but
I'd marry you with paper rings like no
you wouldn't because neither would I
like when you're rich like be rich [__]
like stop be rich so we can look up like
and be like wow once again though she
has a wedding coming up I know this is a
courthouse and again Courthouse thing
but she did like a whole photo shoot so
everyone is treating it like a real
wedding got it got it I mean again could
not be me and if I had that kind of
money right could not be me her husband
is Rich too I believe if he plays in the
NFL like we're all rich like let's start
acting like it what do you say yes
that's why that's why we want to watch
you besides the fact that you are an
incredible app right that's definitely
part of the Allure are you watching Love
is Blind
a little bit okay are you aware of the
controversy going on with the hosts
Vanessa and Nick Lachey yes so people
are really unhappy with them I feel like
a lot of the criticism is warranted but
it's definitely been blown out of
proportion and now they're like
legitimate rumor circulating in our next
story that Lauren speed Hamilton and
Cameron Hamilton who are a couple who
got married on the first season who
everyone is obsessed with and now have
like a YouTube channel whatever that
they might replace Nick and Vanessa
Lachey after all the backlash okay they
first of all I feel like their
relationship was like completely just a
PR relationship who not Vanessa oh you
think Lord you don't believe in their
love not really did you watch a season I
watched like multiple episodes I feel
like if you really watch the season in
full like you would know how real it is
like you think they're fully they're so
in love they're really like perfect for
each other it's a true definition of
like Opposites Attract he's like this
nerdy scientist who's really quiet and
she's just like effervescent outgoing
yeah he's a Sheldon and she is very much
like this outgoing you know bubbly the
loud one and them together like perfect
match like Opposites Attract perfection
okay she's like loves fashion she's very
colorful
call me in a year from now when they're
not together anymore okay I just want to
say love is blind for Susan has to have
been it was during covid three years ago
so there's and they got married a year
the show was filmed actually a year
prior so they've been married now
probably four years
okay I take everything I just said back
I think you should okay fine deal you
win that one a hundred percent so
everyone is saying now that like they're
gonna replace Nick and Vanessa Lachey
because like people were hating on Nick
of Vanessa for how they acted during the
reunion it was an unedited live reunion
I don't think it's really fair to judge
someone because we're used to watching
like Andy Cohen blah blah and those are
reunions that are filmed for 13 hours
and then put into two and a half or
three hour episodes right so it's not
really fair to judge them based on that
and I thought people were like being you
know blowing this thing out of
proportion but there is like an Insider
on Love is Blind who are saying there's
always been whispers about replacing
them with Lauren and Cameron especially
now after the live reunion special which
was such a disaster on so many levels if
Netflix wants to keep their ratings up
there has to be a big change I don't
know I don't really believe this Insider
and I'm very here for Cameron and Lauren
potentially being the host but well
because they've lived it they've lived
it but like being a host is not all like
it's cracked up to be it's actually a
skill you need to have and like just
because you were on reality TV and
you're an influencer that actually
doesn't make you like Vanessa Lachey is
a bona fide host like she was on TRL or
whatever her life her former life was
explain to me just very quickly what
exactly people are upset about she just
she like she was acting like an animal
on the reunion like drunk right what do
you mean like an animal so point of
being like a moderator and a host is
like you really have to be impartial you
have to ask questions that push the the
needle on both sides and she just felt
like she came in with this like [__]
Vendetta and she was like going after
people and it felt really personal she
actually sent flowers to one of the
contestants who she was like really hard
on for like probably no reason and her
job is to be hard on everyone but she
was definitely taking sides she was just
staying some like weird [__] out of
pocket [__] and she's active give me an
example please okay she was like they
showed this video they showed this video
of Jackie and Josh or this couple but
Jackie was actually engaged to Marshall
okay and Marshall was sitting at the
reunion and she was like rubbing in his
face all the things that like this new
couple his old fiance and her new
boyfriend were talking about and it just
felt like she was like trying to get him
to cry like she stated on him yeah she
was she went through that with everyone
she would like fixate on someone for 20
minutes and like ask so many questions
be like well why'd you do that and it's
like another example this guy Mike uh
didn't want to anyway sorry this guy
Paul didn't really want to date this
girl Micah anymore because he didn't
really feel like she had like this
nurturing sort of maternal energy that
he was looking for and that's kind of
like a main thing to say so he didn't
say it to her but it ended up that being
the reason and he was she was like well
why didn't you tell Micah that he said
well I didn't want to hurt her feelings
like you can break up with someone and
not like share everything that was wrong
with him you don't want to hurt their
feelings you're breaking up with them
she just like wouldn't let certain
things go and she was also just like
like acting crazy acting insane yeah so
this is this was unedited is that what
you're saying it live did you not hear
about this whole big Netflix live thing
kind of and I heard that she was like so
at 9 00 pm on Sunday like two weeks ago
they're like we're doing a live reunion
which is like crazy is it actually live
that's what I want to know well it was
supposed to be nine o'clock happens 9 15
9 30. nothing's happening Netflix had
crashed they're tweeting oh we'll be up
in 15 minutes we'll be up in 15 minutes
then they ended up not even doing it
they just filmed it and then put it up
for everyone the next day but it was
live and some people were able to watch
it live very few people I actually
weirdly was my Netflix was letting me
watch it live but most of America and
you know the world was not able to watch
it live so the episode that came out the
following day which was the same episode
was that one edited people said it was
okay but it really wasn't I saw I saw
the raw thing she was she really was
acting crazy I just it's just she didn't
do a good job did she okay so it wasn't
like under the influence it was she
wasn't drunk she wasn't drunk is that
what you read
I mean I think I think I did read that
somewhere and also when I just hear
someone acting completely Bizarro I
think there's like substances involved I
know I feel like Nick of Vanessa are
really grounded in terms of like
Hollywood
I'm sorry I have been scrolling Tick
Tock lately I don't know what [__]
trend is happening but all of the scenes
of Nick Lachey and Jessica Simpson from
what was their show oh newlyweds has
your tick tock tick tock been blowing up
without [__] it hasn't been blowing up
but I've always been targeted with that
kind of content but by the way your Tick
Tock is blowing up because you keep
watching and engaging with the videos so
the algorithm thinks you like it and
they keep giving you more right so if
you don't I went down a [__] Rubble I
watched like 50. did you watch that show
when it was like on back in the day I
did I remember like her asking oh my God
it's the chicken yeah it's actually
chicken I do remember bits and pieces
but we were younger we were young and I
watched it because I love Jessica
Simpson and I always have but I don't
remember a lot of the content so
whenever I get served clipped I always
watch it okay Nick Lachey borderline a
[__] [__] did you read Jessica
Simpson's book I did not okay if you're
into celebrity Memoirs it's amazing
every time I have a guest co-host I
literally just try and spend the episode
Pretty convincing them to read this book
A lot of it is about her marriage and he
was a prick I mean you can tell by the
clip especially scene during that time
it was this weird transition where like
when they started started dating he was
much more famous than her 98 Degrees and
then when they got married and they were
living in that house she was never in
the house because she was so busy and
like 98 Degrees was like kind of
flopping and he was going through this
[__] crisis and he was so jealous and
he was very competitive so that's what
we're seeing play out that she gave us a
lot of context in the book for the show
that's what we're seeing he's having
like an identity crisis while his wife
was like reaching new limits that he
never and he was only getting
opportunities because he was her husband
and he was like this egotist and it was
decorating the house behind her back has
to regain his power decorating the house
was like this huge storyline in that
show it's so funny she was like how can
I decorate this house I'm never here and
that was a source of contention he was
like well you're never here because
you're busy and I'm not what a [__] I
know he could not support a successful
woman so maybe he did some [__] to
Vanessa a hundred
eating all of this on [__] Nick I
think that's a really fair and safe
assumption I I hate him how old is he
they're old they're like 40. I like how
I say they're older like older I want
them to come back together 98 Degrees Oh
I thought you're gonna take Nick and
Jessica no what is the 98 Degrees song I
want I was just thinking to look it up
like I want to pull up Spotify yeah
because I feel like they're such a
recognizable band in terms of their name
why do I want to say it's sometimes
everyone I feel like that's in sync
sometimes I hide sometimes no I feel
like that's that's Britney Spears
to hold you tight way off right be with
you day and night actually I think maybe
if I have a beautiful voice
no I'm never singing along with you ever
again oh I have like an amazing
incredible okay the number on the Mast
the mass singer you know one time I said
they asked me to submit like an audition
because like they're always why didn't
you I did are you kidding me I literally
said my bedroom and was like
[Music]
yeah like I really put my whole [__] in
it and I never heard back your voice is
insane their number one song is I Do
Cherish You let's
oh yeah
he was so hot take like Nicki doesn't
really have a good voice no but he was
he is the reason why in middle school I
shaved my armpit you know what I'm
saying yeah were you one of those girls
who would go to like a Jonas Brothers or
like a 90 degrees concert and like shave
your vagina because you thought maybe
like it would be the night you lost your
virginity
um yes it was All American Rejects oh
was that your band of choice and Fall
Out Boy I loved the music from
All-American were you like an emo kid of
one thousand percent are you oh Beyond
like so Secondhand Serenade
what does that even mean to the band
second hand serenade I don't know
tonight will be the night that I will
fall for you oh my God yes yes I think
it's like a song about suicide which was
actually really dark think about the
music we listened to I mean do you know
the the song jumper from semi-charmed
kind of life no from Third Eye Blind I
love wait what is this song called I
wish you would step back from that ledge
my friend I was like rocking outside
definitely about suicide yeah they're
all the songs are about suicide why were
we singing why is it so Poppy and like
upbeat because that was like the punk
movement you know
very interesting that was very much like
an emo kid Fallout Boy like I was
obsessed also liked John Mayer Oh My
Chemical Romance oh my God Ben is
obsessed with My Chemical Romance did
you see that could Charlotte performed
at Sophia Richie's after party I did I
did Lifestyles of the Rich and Famous
but I would have wanted that song I know
but what is good Charlotte's in it like
number one song I don't know that's like
their best song I don't know what it is
but I just that song I think started to
just be playing too much on the radio
it's also weird for like all these rich
and famous people yeah yeah yeah yeah
all right they're number one oh this is
the Anthem throw all your hands up yeah
maybe I don't love good girl but like
that's I would die to have good children
it was just like looped in with like The
All-American Rejects like yeah yes I'll
keep you my dirty Littles that was my
genre of choice I loved that
um okay so I'm over Love is Blind
honestly I feel like we've been talking
about it so much like I just wanted to
say I'm gonna have Peter Gabriel singing
at my wedding even though I'm pretty
sure he's 80 and I would have to like
Life Flight him in who is Peter Gabriel
your eyes
to light the heat your eyes I am how do
you not know about it's a classic so
that too you would have like sing you
down the aisle yeah but just that one
song I would have I would have uh
Gwyneth Paltrow singing me down the
aisle singing the original song from
Country Strong
the world tried to break me I found a
road to take me
Gwyneth Paltrow yeah you know Country
Strong no
I didn't I didn't know Gwyneth Paltrow
had a voice did you never see Glee she
played substitute teacher Holly holiday
on Glee She was like a recurring Cameo
guest character she was amazing she
actually can sing and she's saying she
did a musical Country Strong is
basically like the they made a country
version of A Star is Born it's like kind
of the whole same concept oh and she
plays Kelly canner who's this like big
Reba type like huge who's really
struggling and she falls in love with
this young guitarist and there's this
new hot country artist on the scene
Leighton Meester
I love her it's an amazing song with an
original soundtrack love that and the
final song before spoiler alert Gwyneth
Paltrow kills herself is is um it's
called home coming home it's such a
beautiful song and she sings it on on
the soundtrack okay and what is this
movie called Country Strong I'm gonna go
home and watch it you have to watch it
and fun fact I actually performed it and
sang it at Jackie's Wedding
you're lying no Jackie wanted me to sing
it for her mother-daughter dance and I
sang it and it was like one of the
highlights of my life and then I watched
the videographer like footage and I
sounded so [__] horrible I like
actually apologized to Jackie for
wearing a wedding
the thing is she had me sing after
dessert and I was like black out by then
so I don't even know what to write down
did you have stage fight at all no no it
was friends and family I wasn't coherent
you pulled a Vanessa and I was lit I was
literally like thinking am I not gonna
drink because they came up to me when we
all said we all got into the reception
room The Wedding Planner was like you're
going after dessert I'm like after
dessert that's in like two [__] hours
like I'm not gonna not drink at my
sister's wedding so it was just balls to
the wall and so that was not your best
performance no
yeah I went to a wedding and the groom
played the violin that's so sweet
and it was the cringiest host thing at
what point down the aisle it's one thing
to not have a great voice it is another
thing to butcher the violin and be like
before she walked down the aisle oh
that's like weird because like the
ceremony is really about the bride so to
like make it about you that's a little
cringe yeah and he had left the ring in
the like in the hotel but also rich as
[__] like it didn't really matter and
is there any chance these people are
gonna hear this because you know
everyone on the planet listens to the
toast
um I wasn't thinking about that but I
didn't name names and you stand by what
you said that's always my defense if I
don't name names then I feel like it's
free games if you don't name names you
can be sued that's what I'm saying
that's a really good man and if someone
and this has happened to me and I got in
a lot of trouble I even had like a
couple sponsors pulled out this is the
very beginning of Sophia the nap okay
and I don't know why I'm re-bringing it
up so I lose them again but I told this
story about someone did not name names
didn't really give that much info away
but you know my listeners they figure it
out they work for the FBI they figure it
out and then this said person decided to
go on go on a tick tock Rampage
and Rampage
Rampage yeah
and made a four-part tick tock as to how
I'm the worst human being on planet
Earth actually gonna have to tell me
after who this was I will but also you
wanted that attention right of course
because no one you know like you got a
few DM right like you could have let it
just die yeah if you were that affected
by it oh you already made it I know what
this is I know what it is and Alicia you
know what we'll just I remember seeing
the four part takedown of Sofia with an
F regarding the library book yes you
know it wasn't a library book it was my
[__] diary okay that she had written
in oh then I'm thinking of something
else I'm thinking of someone from your
hometown no that's her that's who it was
okay that's that's who it was wow that
was a crazy time I remember
tackling but I did take out the stuff I
said yeah I went to the best that's a
crazy thing to lose sponsors over like
that's moronic I didn't say her [__]
name I'm so sorry that happened to you
it's okay today's episode is brought to
you by article summer is on its way and
if you've been dreaming up your outdoor
space and how to make the most of it you
gotta check out article because the best
thing about summer is getting to do all
your favorite indoor Tings but outside
having meals watching movies falling
asleep on the couch and articles curated
a catalog of outdoor furniture is here
to help you do all your favorite things
this summer they've got everything you
need to make really
beautiful things and make it your own
with your outdoor sofa outdoor dining
set outdoor decor Jackie's outdoor space
is like really coming along since she
moved she got so many sickening pieces
from article and it's really becoming my
favorite place to spend time in her
house so article believes in delightful
design for every home and thanks to
their online only model they have some
really delightful prices too it's very
true because outdoor furniture like
people are getting out of control out of
control not article they're curate
assortment of mid-century modern Coastal
industrial scandi and boho designs make
furniture shopping simple articles team
of designers are all about finding the
perfect balance between style quality
and price they're dedicated to
thoughtful craftsmanship that stands the
test of time and looks good doing it
they also order they offer excuse me
fast affordable shipping across the U.S
and Canada they won't leave you waiting
around you pick the delivery time
they'll send you updates every step of
the way I will say with Jackie and I've
ordered from article before but
especially the outdoor furniture for
Jackie my God what a difference to all
these other websites article is like so
communicative so on time the wait times
are not crazy and there's no middleman
it's like you're just buying directly
from article and it's fabulous it's so
easy so they're offering our listeners
50 off your first purchase of a hundred
dollars or more so if you want to claim
that go to article.com toast and the
discount will be automatically applied
at checkout that's article.com toast for
50 off your purchase of a hundred
dollars or more
today's episode is brought to you by
Noom Trends and fads come and go
especially when it comes to health and
wellness but Noom is not a fad they use
psychology not Trends to help you make
intentional and sustainable choices that
are aligned with your values and your
weight loss goals so new is different
because it's a psychology-based approach
with their psychology-based approach
Noom is empowering you to build more
sustainable habits and behaviors so this
isn't just like a trend or a diet it's
something that you can really Implement
throughout the rest of your life
um what I really like about Noom though
it's like because it's psychology-based
approach they understand like some days
are just harder than others some days
you're going to slip up and it doesn't
derail all of your progress just have a
bad day like new accounts for that and
you just get back on track the next day
and you don't have to feel bad about it
and start spiraling everyone's journey
is different so the daily lessons you
get from Noom are going to be
personalized to you and your goals and
it's not restrictive it's nourishing so
whatever your health goals are you know
some people want to just feel better
some people want to drop a certain
amount of pounds and people want to fit
into an item of clothing whatever your
goal is the flexible program focuses on
progress instead of perfection you'll
choose your level of support from five
minute daily check-ins to personal
coaching progress is really a straight
line days off are totally okay noon will
just help you get back on track the
first time numbers are losing an average
of 15 pounds after being active in the
program for 16 weeks and 95 percent of
customers say new new is a good
long-term solution so stop chasing
Health Trends and build sustainable
healthy habits with nooms
psychology-based approach sign up for
your trial today at noon.com toast
that's
n-o-o-m.com toast to sign up for your
trial they also have a new book the new
mindset it's a deep dive into the
psychology of behavior change and it's
available to buy wherever you buy books
if that's something you're interested in
um I love to always pick a story about
The Real Housewives of Salt Lake City
when you're here because I know you're
from Salt Lake and like I just like to
get your take on things
um jenshaw's husband Sharif was offered
an appearance on this new season of Real
Housewives of Salt Lake City to talk
about you know everything that's been
going on like do it like a like um a
guy's night or whatever and he is turned
down he does not want to be on the show
and he declined the the offer because
him and Jen were not happy with the way
the network treated Jen after her
sentencing and I don't know what exactly
they're referring to but Jen said in
December 2022 that she would not attend
the Salt Lake City Reunion under legal
advice but she also claimed that Bravo
found this unsatisfactory and they
expected her to discuss the storyline so
Bravo was mad at her for not showing up
to the reunion even though she said she
was doing it because it was in her best
legal interest
um and then the following month Andy
said he hoped for a sit-down interview
with Jennifer Jen Shaw
um he said this specific one-on-one
interview oh sorry Jen said this
specific 101 interview was not a part of
my real housewives of Salt Lake City
reality TV contract and I promised
myself and my loving family that I would
not allow this portion of my life to be
sensationalized or inaccurately conveyed
she elaborated I would rather remain
silent and wait until I'm able to
accurately share my story then continue
having to compete with lies and
misrepresentations about me smeared
across headlines I do have to say I
actually respect her for not doing that
when I want to interview because they
would have paid her a lot of money and
she needed that money for legal fees and
um restitution that she had to pay back
to her victims so I wasn't smartest
decision because she needs the money I
think they paid your Teresa and Joe when
they did that one-on-one interview
before they went to jail seven figures
and they needed that money because they
owed like six seven figures they owed
them they owed the government like seven
million dollars back then so like it
helped and it was embarrassing and
humiliating but they had to do it
see I see this would be my thing is I
guess the she can't legally she already
got her sentencing so right right so she
has nothing to lose right so at that
point I would [__] take the interview
yeah not only is she turning down the
one-on-one interview which would have
been a big payday a smaller payday would
have been Sharif going on and talking
and and so I don't know how they're
expecting there must be in a lot of debt
their mom who was like a school not her
mom who was like a school teacher had
like a million dollars in savings that
she saved her whole life like for her
and she gave it to Jen
for her legal fees so like Jen has crazy
legal fees she has restitution she has
all these expenses and so it's really
not smart like not because their income
up until this point was Jen's fraudulent
business which she can't do anymore
Sharif is an assistant football coach
for like a small College I don't think
that's like a lot of money so I don't
know what her plan is to pay back these
bills so I don't know if she should just
be turning down these opportunities
because these opportunities don't last
forever people move on
ah I don't know because okay Billy
McFarland yeah was in jail for six years
did you have him on your podcast I did
that's crazy very interesting guy what
was it like in person I I couldn't tell
if what he was saying was genuine or not
right right that's leaning towards not
so much I know that's like a true
definition of a con artist it's like you
really never know what they're saying
yeah it was very interesting also he
texted me like a few weeks ago and he's
like I just released this dating app
would love for you to like be a part of
it you were gonna say yes you had on a
date no no would you ever he has a
girlfriend oh but would you ever like
just for the Press
Billy McFarland no okay okay no but he
was in prison I'm pretty sure for six
years with um Mike The Situation they
crossed paths isn't that crazy
I that is the most incredible [__] I've
ever [__] heard that's when like
being a fan of Pop Culture becomes so
fun and Mike was in there for tax
evasion very interesting so Billy
McFarland is he's chilling right now Jen
you don't think Jen six years from now
can release a book yeah she definitely
can be back in the Limelight like I
think she can make money I think she can
too
but it's always good to strike while the
iron is hot you really never know what's
going to be going on in the world in six
years like six years from now will we
really care with Teresa like she had
been on our TV for 10 years like we were
in love with her like we knew her we
knew her family and she only went away
for 15 months so we only had to wait
like a year and three months for her to
release the book and get an interview
Jen we've only known for two years Jen's
going away for seven years like oh my
God will we still care in seven years
about a woman we barely know I don't
know maybe it depends how good the
[__] book is and it depends like what
kind of content she's gonna be putting
out up until then like is she gonna be
making videos in prison like how does
that whole thing work because I am very
confused I know Teresa was like posing
for photos with her inmates and like
selling them to People magazine when she
was in prison I don't know how it works
but I do believe when you're like a
celebrity and you commit a white collar
crime you go to like more it's it's more
of a camp kind of where like Lori
Lachlan and Felicity Huffman went they
go to special places where that's where
uh the Chrisleys are right now right so
maybe you know you can get a visitor
with a cell phone I don't know I also
have ended up on Prison Talk where
prisoners in like real maximum security
prisons are you know doing the Renegade
in their uh in there in their cells
because apart it's like a big ring in um
you know you sell cigarettes you sell of
course of course like dirty magazines
they sell cell phones and you could buy
a cell phone in prison actually they say
it's very easy to get a cell phone in
prison well Joe Exotic yes I'm pretty
sure he is selling podcast interviews
he's like charging people oh but you can
also call yeah you can call you can call
an inmate and I guess you can record the
phone call and release it as a podcast
if there's anyone listening to this
podcast in prison and wants to come on
the toast while Jackie's out maybe I'll
get an inmate co-host I actually thought
about doing that I think it's a
brilliant concept for a podcast I should
start like a pen pal a pen pal you can
write to inmates and stuff yes you can I
also ended up on a side of tick tock
where a lot of the women were talking
about how they do like cosmetics and
daily hygiene in prison and it was
actually very interesting how they put
on eyeliner and how they made lipstick
so eyeliner they would take lead pencils
and like dip it in water okay and
literally make eyeliner out of that
would you care about wearing eyeliner if
you were not in the slightest but I
guess to establish a sense of normalcy a
lot of women feel like wearing makeup
makes them feel more like a
participating
member of society yeah even though
they're actually not in prison
um and then for lipstick they would take
like sour candy and like melt the gummy
it was crazy sometimes it would even
take Dorito dust and make it into
lipstick that I don't know I really
think that would be the last thing on my
priority list yeah I would be like yummy
food yeah maybe drugs just like just to
pass the time you know yeah moonshine
they like make alcohol out of like dirty
bath water exactly Oh I thought it was
toilet water you can make wine okay I've
heard that yeah I mean I learned a lot
watching Orange is the New Black I've
never seen that show oh it was a good
show it was yeah you don't need to watch
like all the seasons first one was good
okay
um yeah so I learned a lot from being on
the prison side of tick tock and it was
very interesting and I hope jenshaw I
don't think the facility Jen Shaw is in
requires these types of things because
these are for like Maximum Security
Prison for like people who do like armed
robbery and stuff
um but it was very fascinating to be on
that side of tick tock that is very
fascinating I want to look into it by
the way I have been arrested three times
no I never went to prison I did go to
jail I feel like I always bring this up
with you by the way I forgot the last
time you were on the podcast you told
that story and I need you to repeat it
because hey I forgot and B we have like
a lot of new listeners so you you've
been arrested and like gone to County
like where they just hold you right so
I've been arrested and just thrown in
the drunk team right right and that's
was what two times yes okay and then and
the drunk take what do you do just leave
it off
you uh there's not really a lot of
sleeping because it's like a little bit
terrifying because it's not just drunk
people in the drunk tank there's people
that are coming off meth for people who
you know are in there for a whole
different host of reasons yes uh but
then one time and by the way this
Probably sounds like I have a huge
[__] alcohol problem with my [__]
Spritz here this is Utah where there is
no crime happening right and they're
also really strict about alcohol in Utah
because they're very LDS which is Mormon
and so alcohol me underage it was like
they're looking for you yeah so you were
an easy target I was so then one of the
time this was the final time because
they scared me shitless yeah I believe
um I actually got booked in to the jail
and they were really trying to scare me
and teach me a lesson and they told me
we have no idea when you're getting out
because there's um a holiday coming up
you could be in here for like a week
and I had to do the jumpsuit the orange
jumpsuit I had to do the bend over and
cough they took out my extensions I was
very upset about this cell mate yeah I
had to sell me what was she like the
most terrifying human being on planet
Earth to the point that when I first got
into the cell and I was terrified I was
like oh my God I have a cell mate I
thought sell meat like you know like
this is like this like your partner your
partner I can confide in this person and
I said hey she was it was a bunk bed no
she was on the top bank and I said hey
um she didn't say anything to me by the
way when I got in there but I said
finally I was like hi I
um just like wanted to introduce myself
I'm Sophia and I'm really really scared
like to be in here what can I expect and
I will never forget her response which
was
it is way better in here than it is out
there
out there meaning what the world like
outside of jail oh so that I think that
you know yeah kind of gives you some
background as to where she came from
also she did come crawling down from the
top of the bank I only saw her one time
because I told her she could eat my food
because it was so disgusting what was it
I don't even remember but I remember
having one bite and I was in shock I
think it was like white bread with like
baloney but it was crazy yeah yeah did
not taste like baloney just no
um and it was very apparent she was like
a meth head like sores everywhere this
big uh
did you kind of sandwich more than you
did she did she did and then she just
crawled back up and never spoke to me
that's so like you have lived so many
lives
like that was some crazy [__] that was a
really crazy time in my life and so you
have like a record technically I got it
expunged a couple years ago does that
mean you can vote I can vote you can I
can't get into I can't get [__]
Global and you told me that you can't
get Global Entry but so how can you vote
I they're two different I don't know I'm
a Flight Risk if I'm traveling
internationally is there anything else
you can't do because no okay that's good
so you were a minor when it happened so
that's why they expunge it
um one of them so two of them were I was
under 18 one of them I think I was 20.
got it I was turning 21 the next day how
[__] up is that oh that's tough it was
your 21st birthday wow what a life you
have lived yeah moving on um Meghan
Trainor is telling us things we don't
want to know um on her podcast and I
think she's just trying to uh put out
some
sort of deflectors because she's getting
canceled right now for something she
said about teachers did you hear about
this about teachers yeah she basically
was like going on a rant about school on
her podcast and she said [__] teachers
and every teacher is like oh my God how
could you say that but again I mean so
now she's putting out dumb press like
this she's telling everyone she can't
walk after nightmare sex with her big
boy husband her words not mine this
singer on her work in it working on a
podcast told listeners that intercourse
is so painful with her quote Big Boy
husband she said she can't walk
afterwards she admitted that she wishes
um she could make her husband smaller
she said it's to the point where I'm
like is it all in and he says just the
tip and I'm like no I can't do it
anymore I don't know how to fix that she
said she also let everyone know she's
been diagnosed with vaginismus which is
defined as involuntary tensing of the
vagina
so that's what's going on with Meghan
Trainor do you think this is completely
made up why because she wants everyone
to think her husband has a big dick yeah
um and just for views and attention yeah
I could definitely see like her husband
having a big dick like you never know
it's always the unsuspecting ones Judy
from Spy Kids yeah sure he's a big dick
I just feel and I really feel really
strongly about this um like some things
are okay to you know keep to yourself so
Claudia if you remember
we were at a spritz Center I was sitting
next to you and I showed you a picture
of the guy this guy that I was dating at
the time his penis you did and looking
back I think that's a very good sign
that you don't really like that person
to be sharing that kind of information
with other people oh my God that's a
really good
like you want to keep that
dick yes
so right because I would never say
something about this like a Batman
exactly because it's so intimate
especially when it's like a relationship
or you're married like that's such a
good point so it showed like how much
lack of respect I had in that
relationship and Megan's doing the same
thing here oh my God look at you that is
like a really good point I mean therapy
yeah because it's one thing to like hype
him up and be like he has a big dick but
like you're also saying like just
sharing intimate parts of your personal
life and your sex life that really is
nobody's business right also her vagina
will just tense uh she has vaginismus
vaginous involuntary tensing of the
vagina I wish her mouth had that
well she is like not having a good week
and it's clear that like her publicists
are putting this out to kind of you know
[__] with her SEO because she is getting
[__] dragged because the teacher
comments yeah the teacher is not a group
you want to [__] with on the internet I
have been there before and I just want
to say I respect and love teachers but I
do stand by what I said at the time
which was this and I don't want to bring
it up but like we're bringing up all
this [__] that like it was a story okay
Reese Witherspoon has a brand called
Draper James and they did this really
nice thing for like National Teachers
Day where she was like go to the link in
our bio and apply and give us your
credentials and we're sending uh all the
teachers free dresses okay and they said
that they were going to do like maybe a
thousand teachers or whatever and the
post went viral and every teacher in
America wanted to dress because it's
really cute dresses perfect for teaching
and like millions of teachers applied
and of course it's a small brand they
can't give away Millions so they said
like oh we've been overwhelmed like
sorry we can't give out to everyone but
we're doing as many as we can and the
teachers got so mad and I just said it
when we were recap the story on the toes
I'm like all right well you know what
she's trying to do a nice thing like
sucks that like maybe the wording was
confusing and everyone thought they were
getting a free dress but like you're not
and like calm down oh the teachers
[__] came for me that I didn't have
their back and I love teachers I respect
teachers I raised money for teachers
every year on on Amazon like I I love
teachers but I was just saying I thought
the teachers would be like a lot of
control it's a dress it's a dress it's a
[__] dress so then Trisha Paytas made
the mistake she obviously didn't learn
from my mistakes you do not [__] with
the teachers okay so that is one group
we do not keep that in mind keep that in
mind I'm going to and Disney stars
Disney's yeah yeah why why am I doing
this myself okay continue so Meghan
Trainor can't have sex with her husband
but she has a baby so she's obviously
doing she has one on the way too well
thank God she had a C-section cracked oh
yeah because of her imagination I guess
because her baby would come out like
what toothpaste because she would be
tensing right because her vagina is this
small
good afternoon I don't know if her
vagina his husband's penis is just so
big
I'm just saying thank God for this he's
like now we're talking about this when
we shouldn't be but it's because she
opened the door you know well I talk
about this stuff on my podcast open but
you were talking about this if she
didn't bring it up no but I wouldn't be
talking about Meghan Trainor I'd like
her as a person her music it just again
played way too many times on the radio I
happen to like her music but I hear what
you're saying it's not for everyone all
right but the final story is the latest
in the fast food industry because we
just have to talk about food on the show
Wendy's Wendy's is starting a new
Revenue stream and they're going to be
selling their famous chili but in a can
now and it's going to be in grocery
stores
so their famous chili is typically
typically sold hot at restaurants but
soon they're going to sell it canned
from a grocery store so they're
partnering up with like a big
conglomerate to bring the Beloved chili
into homes across the country it'll be a
can for 4.49 which is like kind of a lot
for a can and it'll be hitting shelves
this spring
okay so when I think of Wendy's the
chili is not my you know what I think of
me neither but that's because I don't
eat chili from Wendy's but I think
you've got a lot of people it is what
they think of I think about their chili
sauce which is the most insane
incredible I don't know how to explain
it is it like in a packet oh and it's
their own chili Wendy sauce and it's
incredible to the point that like I
remember one time this is when I was
living in Utah so it was a little bit
different I called my ubereats driver
to confirm that he would get it I called
the Wendy's that he was going to to make
sure to confirmed that they would put it
in the bag they didn't but it's really
good so now that they're like moving
into grocery maybe they'll now be doing
like Chick-fil-A sales their their
famous sauces like in the condiment
style maybe now this is their foray into
selling their chili sauce or any other
famous sauces in the condiments aisle
just chilling like chili in a can I know
I didn't know canned chili was a thing
but then I thought maybe I'm just
uneducated because I make my chili fresh
I don't really I'm not a real chili
person my mom's never made chili once in
her life no my husband like made me fall
in love with it he makes the best chili
and I don't know if you know like kind
of a core tenant of the toast is chili
we talk about chili every day okay so I
[__] love chili I Love Actually I
love you you should come to my house and
have Ben's Chili I want to it's the best
salad it will change me it will change
you and I don't like beans I don't even
really like that chili I literally Ben
makes of that and I freeze it and I eat
it for months like all through the
winter okay well now I'm excited I want
to try it so good dead so maybe we
should get this Wendy's chili a try
Wendy's chili like is known to be very
good I don't know how it's going to
translate in a can yeah I want to know
Ben's perspective on Wendy on Wendy's
chili I don't think Ben's ever had it
because we keep kosher for the most part
right
um but I feel like there was a time in
Ben's life where he was like very
relaxed with the laws of kashrut and I
wonder if you ever had it he's not a
chili like a fast food Chili guy he's a
very much like a Subway Jimmy John's you
know sandwich type of guy he's going for
a turkey Italian sub me too really I'm a
sandwich girl I [__] hate Subs like I
don't eat any of them what are your um
thoughts what do you think is the best
sub chain Subway Subway Jimmy John's
what's the other one everyone always
goes to
um Jersey Mike's Jersey Mike's I feel
like there's other ones but I
love Subway what do you think about the
smell in the restaurants
it reminds me of my childhood oh that's
sweet okay I love it okay I love it um
all right those were the past five
stories you certainly didn't need to
know any of them but um we're not done
because it's Wednesday and that's where
we Dole out interesting advice for
interesting people and we do our best to
help them okay great so we have three
submissions from three different girlies
in need if you guys want to write in
remember the email account is
deertoesters gmail.com and keep it brief
because some of you guys are just
writing and things that are too long and
we can't read them today's episode is
brought to you by primallypure if you
want to have your healthiest year yet
and become the most vibrant version of
yourself start here cleaning up your
skin care products swapping for natural
options is a must if you want to feel
good and glow from the inside out and
primarily pure has harnessed the power
of natural ingredients in their complete
line of non-toxic beauty products so
from Skin Body baby hair and home and
you can't forget they're called
following natural deodorant primarily
pure products are handcrafted with real
raw ingredients to optimize your results
and your overall health so Jackie of
course is on her health journey and we
both became obsessed with primally pure
because Jackie started using their
deodorant during pregnancy and then
after pregnancy and then we just fell in
love with the brand and started using so
many of their products and now we're so
excited to be partnering with them um
and if you look at their Instagram their
crazy testimonials I mean it's proof
that their pure ingredients really do
create positive change in your skin you
won't believe the before and after
photos and the transfer transformation
stories from their Community across the
world so they handcraft their natural
skin care they create educational
content and they cultivate intentional
community and they offer organic facials
at their holistic Spa primally pure
exists to help Empower you to not only
improve your skin but to lead a
healthier more fulfilling life so if
you're on the fence about making the
swap to non-toxic products especially
natural deodorant check out their five
star reviews at primallypure.com you'll
see it from just from customers like you
and then once you're convinced use code
toast for 15 off your primally pure
purchase that's
www.primalypure.com toast use code toast
at checkout for 15 off your order all
right ready I feel like you'll be able
to help with this one a lot because
honestly I don't know what to say hi
ladies I'm in desperate need of just
some honest and Anonymous advice I'm a
girl I'm engaged to a guy we've been
together for almost a decade he's my
best friend we've been planning our
wedding for the next fall we are so
excited we're both in our 20s
recently I've had somewhat of a
self-discovery I made a new friend who's
another girl and I think I realized I
want to experiment sex with a woman I
truly don't see myself ever being in a
romantic relationship with a woman but
it's like the secret desire I've always
had I've always watched lesbian porn is
that normal do I talk to my fiance about
it he's always been so supportive of
legitimately everything but I'm scared
to hurt him by being this honest what
should I do
okay a you liking lesbian porn and not
you Claudia this person
is completely normal and I have heard
that it has nothing to do with your
preference your sexual preference in
reality yes I landed on a side of chick
talk about lesbian porn don't ask that's
how I know everything and they said that
it's very common for straight women to
like lesbian porn because lesbian porn
fixates on the female experience in sex
when like hetero porn is just like big
dicks like exactly it's not really about
the woman yes and you assume the woman
knows what to do to the other woman
right I personally watch lesbian porn
when I watch porn usually thank you for
sharing thank you
um the second thing she wants to
experiment but she's engaged yeah and
she's afraid like admitting to her
fiance that like she is potentially
interested in a woman
will like scare him he won't be
supportive but I also feel like you know
it also could be a slippery slope like
I think being interested in a woman if
you do it in an experiment it could be
something you just want to get out of
your system and try or it could be you
know your new lifestyle
so I need to know how strong the urge is
it's if she's writing into us it's it's
strong it's very very strong I would be
upfront and honest with your fiance
because ideally like maybe he'd be down
and like in the ideal scenario like it
would be a threesome yeah right and
obviously this is my toxic advice that I
like to get along with the healthy just
downplay the hell out of it okay babe
every single girl goes through this like
you know I should have gone through it
in college but I didn't obviously I'm
not really I just it's something I want
to try I love you I'm obviously marrying
you just just downplay it yeah but I do
think you should like kind of explore it
because you don't have regrets getting
married like this is an important time I
think you should lean in yes I agree
have you had an experimental phase yes
oh yeah 100 when in college you have to
answer if you don't want to sorry no
that's like a rude question no excuse me
my podcast I open book
um College yes I hope up with actually a
few women I would consider myself
straight okay it was just like a fun
thing got it
I don't know I do consider myself
straight I want a husband yeah but I
think like sexuality is like so fluid
like it's like it really is I don't feel
like you even need to like label it like
no I don't but I sometimes think about
it you know right but when it comes to
dating you're not dating men I mean
excuse me women no I don't actively seek
that right like on hinge it's just for
guys exactly interesting all right I
think we gave some good advice tread
lightly but go for it you'll regret it
if you don't mm-hmm
hey guys love the show thanks for
bringing so much joy to my daily commute
you're welcome here's the situation I'm
a teacher and I need some help on how to
navigate a situation with my co-worker
every time she's on her period not only
does she announce it to us but she
leaves Blood on the surfaces in the
communal bathroom she leaves Blood on
the toilet in the sink sometimes on the
floor she's told us that she uses a
menstrual cup so blood in the sink makes
sense to an extent how the hell do I
approach this with her there's only
three of us that are in that bathroom
and I've already checked with my other
longtime co-workers so I know it's not
her I barely know this woman and I don't
want to offend her but I'm also not
trying to clean up after a 35 year old
woman's blood every month when I need to
pee any help you can provide would be
great you know I always say this with
your toasters because sometimes it's
okay and it's the right situation for an
anonymous letter
an anonymous letter to her maybe like
make a memo about the women's bathroom
like maybe okay I got it make a memo
that like claims it's from the
janitorial staff yes I was gonna say the
school administration and be like please
ladies on their periods please clean up
after yourselves we have found blood on
this and while you know we are happy to
clean the facilities this is not a part
of our job description like right I love
fancy memo and tape it to the back of
the stall door that that's problem
solved I love that do you think there's
any way that they could get in trouble
no by asking that no like don't leave
your blood
by the way make a fake memo yes leave it
up for one day so that she sees it and
then you can take it out you know she's
gonna rip that flyer off go running out
and be like what kind of [__] is
this really if by the way if if being
told to clean up after her [__]
period is gonna trigger her then this
woman has other problems too and
honestly it's better to know about them
now have you ever used a menstrual cup
ever have you no I'm a tampon for life I
mean uh I wanna try it the diva cup like
the menstrual cup yes because one time I
had a tampon stuck inside of me for a
month that I was not aware of and
because you just forgot it or got stuck
no I forgot I have no idea how it
happened and then I thought maybe I had
like a yeast infection or something
right because it was problematic and I
went and pushed it up it was the
craziest thing also and she pulled
something out of my vagina and I said
what the [__] was that and she said it
was a tampon so when she pulled it out
did you look at it
did you see what it looked like what
does a tampon look like after it's been
up your vagina for a month I think it it
like it's not like it like disintegrates
it's just like I'm just curious I think
it was just like taking a regular tampon
out and you know how lucky you are
you're gonna get like toxic shock
syndrome yes yes that's crazy so tampons
do kind of scare me now there is an
element about tampons like growing up I
was not allowed to wear a tampon and
then like in high school I was like
[__] I'm sorry I need a tampon we like
used to hide them from our mom I mean
like she still hates that we wear them
but like we're adults now so we get to
do what we want
um but there is like a it's not for no
reason like a lot there is like a lot of
crazy [__] about tampons TSS and I'm
sure more things will start come out I
know that's what happens like we all
start using something and then like
years later it's like wait that was
really bad I know but this is what I'm
supposed to use a pad well this
menstrual cup what I have to bleed like
on your couch right now no and like do
you know what like I'm supposed to shove
that whole thing up my vagina they look
crazy and I know they're like silicone
so they fold into like basically the
size of a tampon but until I find
something that is as convenient and by
the way I'm supposed to put all my
fingers on my vagina okay Meghan Trainor
you're so right you're calling me out
okay moving on make sure
Anonymous letter Anonymous letter moving
on thank you Sophia for calling me out
ready
yes okay this one's [__] weird
okay here's the background information
she sent us I'm a first time soon to be
Mom I'm 30. my boyfriend of two years is
29 we live together and he's always been
a page on PJ means precious gem of a man
precious gem of a man p-g-o-m okay and a
woman is a peach ow okay I just found
out that my boyfriend who I'm about to
have a baby with secretly applied to be
a sperm donor two weeks ago I saw the
application in his email would you not
come for money we often struggle
financially but we work really hard
which is why money is the only reason I
can fathom this justification however
I'm so sad my trust feels broken and I
can't even process I need advice on what
to do and or how to bring it up am I
blowing this up or is this grounds for
breaking up he doesn't know I found out
yet love you guys thank you so much
sincerely a sad and Confused soon to be
Mom that's [__] heartbreaking and
honestly you're not blowing it up you
have literally that's a decision you
make together that's crazy it's his body
our choice like that's [__] weird a
thousand percent and like you're a mom
so this affects you because he's the mom
of your child and like then you have
potential step siblings out there like
you have every right to be mad you
should bring it up as soon as possible
because if you're really not comfortable
with it I'm sure there's a way he can
like get it back you know and tell him
not to because he doesn't consent
anymore like whatever yeah
um talk about it immediate lately
it would be hard for me not to like blow
up but I guess like you have to be
measured if you want to take you
seriously but like you're totally
justified in being pissed like I would I
would you don't need to be you can I
think you can go crazy I know but then
he's just gonna chalk it up like oh my
wife is pregnant and hormonal and crazy
like no you need to really explain why a
this is a huge breach of trust be it's
like Beyond inappropriate when like
you're having a baby together and like
for him to not even that's confide in
you to do that while she's pregnant is
ballsy also I feel like sometimes men in
particular will not actually take you
seriously or listen to you unless you're
acting like the Incredible Hulk oh you
think during the fight I feel like
they'll then just like chalk it up to
you being crazy and not actually listen
to what you say depends on what type of
guy yeah you know your your partner best
like however is the way like to really
get through his head how actually angry
you are whether that's flying off the
[__] handle or sitting down like
giving him a PowerPoint presentation
right sometimes that works too a
PowerPoint never hurts I want to know
how you handle arguments are you a
powerpoint gal or like a it depends on
the argument okay so if it's like let's
say I found something out and like I
ruminated on it and I like if this was
me I would be so measured I would like
because it would be really important to
me that he knows how angry I am and I'm
not like being you know just crazy for
no reason which I can be yep so for
something like that I would be very
tactical but other things like when we
were fighting and like um and like it's
not that important like I'm [__] nuts
[__] like I'm so crazy I've absolutely
done that and I like go to a like a dark
place and like I'll like say something I
regret which is like something I'm
really working on but not in therapy
it's like internally just like in
actuality which I think is a better way
to work on things Okay and like in
practice in practice okay yeah and I
actually have gone I've gotten way
better like when I was we've been
together for a really long time and I
was like really young I was like 18 when
we met in the beginning I was so [__]
toxic that is completely excusable I
don't know why he stayed with me I was
like such a [__] you guys have known
each other since you were 18. that's
insane but I agree with you I think for
in this particular instance because she
just saw it on the computer she doesn't
know the background story right what if
he just like wanted to know how much
money there was out there and then was
gonna ask right but it seems like he
went through with it
oh he the sperm is out the door and
that's what kind of Let Me Maybe not
into a vagina but I think it's in the
bank
okay she saw the application okay maybe
he hasn't sent in the application but
you know what time is of the essence
here so you gotta act now act now but
don't go in Incredible Hulk style unless
you have all of the information and
unless you think that will really like
resonate with him whatever you know him
best like whatever will scare him
[__] shitless and do that yeah and
say that you are donating your eggs yeah
and you already have yeah mm-hmm love
that see how he feels and there's 20
many needs of you yes see how he feels
and tell him you did it for free
so then he'll be like wait you sold your
eggs how much money is that because eggs
are like charity it was a charity yeah
eggs are like 20 rounded pop it's crazy
like no I was just trying to help some
people out yeah like I I'd love to see
families flourishing
um all right that was your toasters Our
advice segment if you ever want to write
in it's your toasters gmail.com Sophia
we love having you here thank you so
much Claudia this was actually very very
very fun actually no it was gonna be fun
but this was more fun than I even
anticipated if you guys liked what you
heard which I don't know how you can't
check out Sophia's podcast Sophia with
an app you drop episodes every week what
day do you drop let me guess Tuesday
um Thursday but Wednesday night got it
so Thursday
um thank you guys so much for listening
to the toast uh tomorrow's episode will
be audio only with Jackie and Friday's
episode will be audio only with Shannon
Ford because we are headed to Palm
Springs for Stagecoach and Shannon and I
are going to be podcasting do you know
Shannon I have never met her I've heard
incredible things I am so jealous you're
going to Stagecoach oh my god do you
want to come I was invited but you're
going to Vegas
why I don't know I'm pissed you should
podcast with Shannon I want to I want to
meet her really bad I'm so [__] cool
and fun and like so pretty and you would
think she would be like a [__] because
she can because she's literally a model
you never met someone nicer she seems
extremely funny she's so fun to go out
with too uh yes I want to meet her okay
um thank you guys so much for listening
to the toast the Monday Morning Show
where we deliver the past five stories
you need to know every Monday through
Friday on YouTube so for watching this
on YouTube please feel free to subscribe
and give this video a thumbs up we're
also available podcast anywhere
podcasting we found so on Spotify iTunes
digital public radio I already castbox
all the places
we are hope you guys have a great day
we'll see you tomorrow and Friday Audio
Only bye bye